.
REMEMBER, EVERYONE, IT'S AMERICA
NOW AND FOREVER.
♪ ♪
>> THE DELTA VARIANT HAS VERY
VISIBLY REDUCE THE PRICE OF
STUPID.
AND BECAUSE IT HAS RAISED THE
PRICE OF STUPID, ENTRENCHED
STUPIDITY COME AT A PRICE HAS
GONE UP AS THE COST OF STUPID
AND THE STUPID POLITICS THAT
WENT ALONG WITH THAT, THE COST
OF STUPID HAS RISEN.
THE ONE THAT'S THE FIRST THING
THAT JOE AND HIS WIFE SAY TO
EACH OTHER WHEN THEY WAKE UP.
>> TERRIBLE PEOPLE.
♪ ♪
♪ YEAH, YEAH.
[LAUGHTER]
♪ ♪
♪
>> IT'S BEEN 20 YEARS SINCE
9/11.
WHAT IS IT LIKE THE PERSON IT'S
NOT 20?
DO THEY KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED THAT DAY TO PRODUCE A
COGENT OPINION?
ONCE YOU LOOK AT THE LATEST
CAMPUS REFORM, THE ANSWER IS GOD
HELP US.
>> DID YOU LEARN A LOT ABOUT
9/11 GLOW OF HER GROWING UP IN
THE CLASSROOM?
>> NOT IN THE CLASSROOM, BUT I
DID MY OWN RESEARCH THING.
>> NO, I DID NOT.
>> I THINK WE LEARNED A MODERATE
AMOUNT.
>> I DIDN'T LEARN THIS SUPER
SPECIFICS, WE HAVE A UNIT, WHICH
WAS A LITTLE STRANGE.
>> DEFINITELY, MY FAMILY HAS
BEEN VERY CONSCIOUS AND
SOMETHING THAT THEY TAUGHT US
ABOUT.
>> THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS
ABOUT AS COMFORTING AS SOMEONE
LOOKING AT HER WATCH DURING A
FUNERAL.
THAT THEY WERE YOUNG, ALL KIND
OF SILLY BACK THEN COME ABOUT
GIVEN THE CHANCE, WHAT WOULD
THEY WANT PEOPLE TO LEARN ABOUT
9/11?
>> I THINK THAT WE SHOULD AVOID
TALKING ABOUT THE ROOTS IN ISLAM
BECAUSE THAT WAS A EXTREMIST
GROUP.
>> I THINK THAT THE 9/11 ATTACKS
SHOULD BE TAUGHT IN A WAY THAT
DOESN'T REALLY TARGET MORE LIKE
WHO DID IT BUT MORE LIKE HOW WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD IN DIFFERENT
HEALING PROCESSES THAT WE CAN GO
THROUGH TO MAKE EVERYTHING, YOU
KNOW, GOOD AGAIN.
>> YOU DON'T THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHO WAS
RESPONSIBLE?
>> I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KNOW WHO IS RESPONSIBLE, BUT I
ALSO THINK IT SHOULD BE NOTED
THAT RELIGION IS NOT THE ONLY
THING.
>> THINGS LIKE ISLAMIC PHOBIA,
IDEAS OF AMERICAN
EXCEPTIONALISM.
>> GROSS.
LOOK, IT'S UNFAIR TO SAY THAT
THESE KIDS ARE REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE POPULATION AS A WHOLE.
BUT WHAT ARE THEY REPRESENTATIVE
OF?
HOW ABOUT AN EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM
THAT IS WORRIED ABOUT
INDOCTRINATION VERSUS
INSTRUCTION, ONE OF WHICH IS
ANTI-AMERICAN VIOLA, SPEWING
FROM PASSIVE AGGRESSIVE
PHYSICALLY UNATTRACTIVE AND
PERPETUALLY WRONG PROFESSORS.
MISDIRECTED ANGER WHO IS
DAMAGING TO SMALL MINDS.
THANKS TO THESE MARXIST THINK
TANK THAT WE CALL UNIVERSITIES,
WE HAVE A FEW GENERATIONS AND NO
LESS ABOUT THIS COUNTRY THAN I
DO ABOUT DUNKING A BASKETBALL,
SOMEHOW EXCEPTIONALISM IS EASIER
TO CONDEMN THAN TERRORISM.
>> THE VIRGINIAN VIRGINITY FROM
EDUCATION SHOWCASE A LECTURE THE
LECTURE AND BASICALLY SAID THAT
WHEN TALKING ABOUT 9/11, WE
SHOULD AVOID TALKING ABOUT
AMERICAN EXCEPTIONALISM.
WOULD YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> YES, FOR SURE, WE SHOULD
BECAUSE WE DON'T NEED MORE
NATIONALISM IN THIS COUNTRY, WE
NEED MORE LIKE -- HEALTH CARE.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> PROPAGATING THIS IDEA THAT
OUR NATION IS THE BEST NO MATTER
WHAT, I WOULD AGREE THAT THAT
SHOULD BE AVOIDED.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT THAT.
>> I DEFINITELY DON'T THINK THAT
AMERICA IS THE BEST COUNTRY ON
EARTH.
WE NEED A LOT OF FIXING.
>> I THINK THAT IT IS A
DANGEROUS MINDSET TO TEACH YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT.
AND THAT IS THE REASON WHY A LOT
OF PEOPLE GREW UP TO BE
EXTREMISTS.
>> I HOPE STUPIDITY IS NOT
CONTAGIOUS.
WHY WOULD SOMEONE THEIR AGE
THINK OF THIS COUNTRY IS
EXCEPTIONAL?
THEY GOT TO THE PARTY LATE.
THEY DON'T KNOW THESE NEW PEOPLE
TO KEEP STRONG AND, PFIZER
BREAKING OUT, THE AUTHORITIES
ARE ON THEIR WAY TO SHUT IT
DOWN.
THEY ARRIVED AS THIS ONCE GREAT
PARTY STARTED WINDING DOWN.
SADLY, TO THEM, SOMETHING
HORRIBLE PERPETRATED AGAINST US
IS JUST ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK ABOUT HOW BAD WE ARE.
SO UNLIKE JESSIE'S HAIR, HISTORY
IS A MALLEABLE THING.
TEACHES THAT AND HOW THEY TEACH
IT CAN DETERMINE HOW YOUR KID
INTERPRETS THE WORLD.
IF THEY ARE TOO YOUNG AND
FEARFUL TO CALL BS, IT'S EASY TO
BE BRAINWASHED.
JUST RECENTLY IT WAS THOUGHT
THAT LESS POLICEMAN WOULD MAKE
US SAFER.
WHAT DO I TELL THEM RIGHT NOW
IT WAS HIS SURREAL AS IT WAS
DEVASTATING BECAUSE I WAS THERE
WHEN IT HAPPENED.
YOU ARE ENGULFED AND IN THE
HEART OF EVIL.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING YOU CAN WALK
OUT OF BECAUSE IT SUCKS AND
YOU'RE IN AND IT CHANGES YOU
FOREVER.
THE SAME WAY A PERSON IS CHANGED
FOREVER IF THEY ARE A VICTIM OF
A VIOLENT CRIME.
YOU CAN'T HAVE THESE BABY TALK
ABOUT THOUGHTS ABOUT SILLY
THINGS OR SHRUG IT OFF AS
SOMETHING WE DESERVE BECAUSE
WERE MEAN AND POWERFUL.
THAT DAY WAS SOMETHING ELSE.
THE SOMETHING ELSE IS CALLED
EVIL.
SADLY, THAT IS FORGOTTEN, MANY
NOW OCCUPY THEIR BRAINS WITH
[BLEEP] WITH GENDER PRONOUNS AND
SELF OBSESSED GRIEVANCE.
BUT IF YOU ARE ON THE 91ST FLOOR
OF A BURNING BUILDING AND THE
FIREMEN CALLED YOU THE WRONG
PRONOUN, YOU WOULD LET IT SLIDE.
SOME EVENTS IN LIFE HAVE A WAY
OF PUTTING THINGS IN
PERSPECTIVE, THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHAT IS IMPORTANT AND
WHAT IS TRIVIAL TWEET AND 9/11
WAS ONE OF THOSE EVENTS.
AND THAT INCLUDES PALESTINE BACK
PAGE NEWS.
BUT AS INTERESTING AS BRITNEY
SPEARS, BLACK LIVES MATTER OR
OTHER TOPICS, THERE'S TOO MUCH
TO THINK ABOUT AND A LOT OF IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE THINKING AT ALL,
THAT FEELING AND LOOKING
IMPORTANT THING WHAT YOU'RE TOLD
TO SAY.
WE HAVE INSULATED THE COUNTRY
SUCCESSFULLY FROM OUR CONFLICTS.
BUT BY INSULATING THEM THEY NOW
HAVE NO VISCERAL RESPONSE TO
THIS MOMENT THAT IMPACTS
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
IT IS SO GOOD THAT PEOPLE DON'T
EVEN KNOW THAT IT IS GOOD.
WE ASSIGN FALSE REREADS THE
LOUDEST VOICES, WHO CAN CRY THE
HARDEST AND CLAIM THEM AS
VICTIMHOOD, THIS RELATES TO
9/11.
ON THAT DAY 20 YEARS AGO WE WERE
MINDED THAT WE WERE AMERICANS,
NOT BLACKS OR WHITES, GAY,
NON-BINARY WOODLAND CREATURES,
WE DID NOT PORTRAY SEPARATE
CATEGORIES.
WE WERE AMERICANS.
TOO BAD THAT IT TOOK 3000
INNOCENT SOULS TO REMIND US OF
THAT.
THAT IS NOT TRIBALISM OR
NATIONALISM BUT UNDERSTANDING
WHAT YOU SHARE WITH EACH OTHER
THAT YOU WERE ATTACKED FOR BEING
YOU.
THE FACT IS IN 2001 WE WERE
AMERICANS.
BUT IN 20 YEARS TIME WE HAVE
BEEN COERCED BY A PROFIT-SEEKING
PROFIT-SEEKING MEDIA TO REJECT
THAT.
YOU CAN ARGUE THAT THEY HAVE
DONE MORE PSYCHOLOGICAL DAMAGE
THAN ANY OTHER OUTSIDE ENEMY,
CREATING A WHOLE INDUSTRY OFF OF
HATING AMERICA.
BECAUSE INCITING WARS BETWEEN
EACH OTHER MEANS PROFITS FOR
COMPANIES, POWERS FOR ACTIVISTS
AND DISTRACTION FROM REAL EVIL.
ON THE 20TH ANNIVERSARY OF 9/11,
WE CALL PEOPLE THAT DON'T WANT A
VACCINE TERRORISTS.
THE FACT IS THAT AS LONG AS WE
ARE AT EACH OTHER'S THROATS, WHO
NEEDS TERRORISTS.
AL QAEDA DID 9/11 AND THE REST
IS A SELF-INFLICTED GUNSHOT
WOUND AS A RESULT OF FRIENDLY
FIRE.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
IF SHE HAD HER WAY SHE WOULD BE
COHOSTING RON GRONKOWSKI
"THE FOUR".
AND WELCOME OUR NEXT GUEST.
, THE TARGET MARKET.
WHEN ASKED WHAT TYRUS DOES FOR A
LIVING HE SAYS BEATS ME.
[CHEERS]
[APPLAUSE]
SO LIKE ME, YOU ARE A HERO.
>> OKAY.
>> WHAT DID YOU DO AFTER 9/11?
>> SO I HAVE BEEN OUT FOR FOUR
AND A HALF YEARS.
I WENT TO CLASSICAL THEATER
SCHOOL, WORKING ACTOR IN
MANHATTAN, AND WE GOT ATTACKED.
WHAT DO I DO NEXT?
I REENLISTED IN THE GREEN BERETS
IN OCTOBER 2001, I RETIRED IN
OCTOBER 2016.
THAT IS WHAT I DID.
I REMEMBER THINKING WHAT DO I
DO.
WELL, NOT TELLING PEOPLE THAT
THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO.
IT ALSO OPEN UP OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES IN OUR MEMBER HOW
I GOT BACK AFTER MY FIRST
APPOINTMENT AND SHE SAID TO ME
SHE HASN'T SEEN ME THIS HAPPY IN
A LONG TIME.
THAT IS WHAT I DID.
AND I DON'T REALLY CARE WHAT YOU
WERE DOING WHEN IT HAPPENED,
WHAT DID YOU DO AFTERWARDS?
HOW DID YOU CHANGE YOURSELF?
DID YOU GET SMARTER?
YOU KINDER?
TO STOP VOTING FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE WORKING FOR YOUR DEMISE?
DID YOU PAY ATTENTION?
I THINK THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
RIGHT OFF THE BAT DID, BUT THEN
I THINK THEY SORT OF STOPPED.
AND I'D LIKE TO SAY SOMETHING
ELSE ABOUT THE YOUNG PEOPLE.
YOU JUST SAW A CLIP OF NOT VERY
SMART, SOFT SHELL CRAB HUMAN
BEINGS.
THERE'S ANOTHER SIDE OF OUR
COUNTRY THAT IS NOT BAD.
YOUNG STUD THAT I SAW COMING IN
THAT PUT ON BODY ARMOR AND KNEW
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO GET HIT.
THESE 19-YEAR-OLD KIDS.
AND IT WAS LET GO, THEY ARE SO
YOUNG, OH, WHO DID YOU THINK
WERE FIGHTING THE WAR IS?
NO, IT'S YOUNG PEOPLE.
IT IS YOUNG PEOPLE DOING IT.
AND SO HARD TIMES MAKE HARD MEN,
HARD MEN MAKE THAT TIMES, GOOD
TIMES MAKE SOFT MEN AND NOW SOTH
SOFT MEN
MAKE OUR HARD TIMES.
THAT'S THE STATE WE ARE IN RIGHT
NOW.
>> I THINK THAT IT COULD HAVE
KILLED THE ACTING CAREER OF
TERRY.
THINK OF ALL THE MOVIES THAT WE
MISSED.
[APPLAUSE]
>> I REALLY FELT IT WAS A MERCY
KILLING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> FIRST OF ALL, I LOVE YOU, I
HATE YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
NOT A FAN OF YOU ANYMORE, AND
YOU COME I HAVE NOTHING TO SAY.
>> SHAME ON YOU GUYS.
>> SO LIKE ME, YOU ARE A HERO.
>> YES.
>> HER LIFE CHANGED.
>> YES, I LOOK BACK ON THE
STAGE.
A LOT OF REFLECTION THIS WEEK.
I THINK THAT WE ARE REMEMBERING
AND COMMEMORATING THIS DAY OF 20
YEARS.
IT FEELS LIKE A MILESTONE AND IS
SOMETHING THAT WHERE YOU HAVE
SOME PEOPLE, WE JUST HAVE TO
MOVE ON.
WE DON'T NEED TO HAVE THESE
MEMORIALS AND LOOK AT WHAT THE
PEOPLE WENT THROUGH.
IMAGINE SUGGESTING THAT THE
UNITED STATES NO LONGER NEEDS TO
TEACH WHAT HAPPENS ABOUT PEARL
HARBOR OR WHAT HAVE AND THE
MARTIN LUTHER KING TUNER.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO GEORGE
FLOYD.
WOULD ANYONE SUGGEST YOU SHOULD
DO THAT?
THIS ONE THEY WANTED TO LET GO
OF BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO
THINK AMERICA IS EXCEPTIONAL
ANYMORE?
>> AMERICA IS A VICTIM HERE,
THEY DON'T WANT TO HEAR THAT
EITHER, WE'RE THE BAD GUY.
ALL OF THOSE OTHER THINGS HE
MENTIONED, YOU CAN ARGUE IS
AMERICA'S FAULT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND THEY DO.
AND I THINK THAT THERE'S A PIECE
IN "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
THAT SAYS IF WE DON'T CONTINUE
TO NEVER FORGET, WE ARE DOOMED
TO REPEAT IT COME OUT WHICH IS
NOT AS ELOQUENT OF AWAY IS WHAT
HE ENDED WITH.
ALSO ON THE VIDEO, I COULD WATCH
THAT ALL DAY, BUT YOU THINK
ABOUT THE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT DIED
OUTSIDE OF THE AIRPORT IN
AFGHANISTAN, THEY WERE SIGNING
UP TO SERVE THEIR COUNTRY IN
ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
COULD SAY WHATEVER THEY NEEDED
TO SAY.
>> I DON'T WANT TO BANG ON THE
SKIDS TOO MUCH, BECAUSE YOU
KNOW, THEY'RE WALKING DOWN THE
STREETS, THEY ARE NOT THINKING
QUITE LIKE THAT.
BUT IT'S ALMOST LIKE THESE
PEOPLE ARE NOT PREPARED.
IF YOU ASK ME ANYTHING ON THE
STREET, THERE'S A 50% CHANCE
THAT I'M ON THE SUBSTANCE AND
WHATEVER COMES OUT OF MY MOUTH
IS GOING TO BE ALL GUMS.
ALL THE BRILLIANT LIKE YOUR
ACTING CAREER.
>> YOU GAVE ME THE ONE LINE THAT
I'M GOING TO BEAT INTO THE
GROUND.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YOU'RE WELCOME FOR YOUR
FREEDOM.
[LAUGHTER]
OKAY, YOU CHOSE NOT TO WEAR
UNDERPANTS.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU DID THIS TO YOURSELF.
>> IF YOU WOULD'VE WORN LEATHER
PANTS I WOULD'VE BEEN MUCH
NICER.
>> OAKUM I'M SURE YOU WOULD
HAVE.
>> I HATE ALL OF THEM.
>> NO CHASSIS OR.
>> NO, NO.
>> SO YOU ARE 36?
>> NO.
>> YOU ARE 11 OR 12.
>> OKAY.
AS A 12-YEAR-OLD, WHAT WAS THAT
LIKE.
>> IS A 12-YEAR-OLD I WAS IN
SCHOOL.
>> WERE YOU A FAT KID?
>> NO I WAS NOT.
THANK YOU, THOUGH, BECAUSE THAT
WOULD'VE BEEN VERY RELEVANT TO
WHAT 9/11 WAS LIKE FOR ME.
AND NOBODY WOULD TELL US WHAT
HAPPENED AND WE DIDN'T HAVE
INTERNET PHONES OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT.
>> WERE YOU AMISH?
[LAUGHTER]
>> WELL, CATHOLIC SCHOOL.
I GOT HOME AND WAS WATCHING TV,
I REMEMBER ASKING MY PARENTS
ABOUT STUFF THAT THEY DIDN'T
REALLY HAVE THE ANSWER TO
BECAUSE THEY WERE JUST AS
SHOCKED AND CONFUSED AS I WAS.
>> IS WHEN THE ADULTS WERE
POWERLESS.
>> YES.
>> I'M KIND OF CURIOUS WHAT YOU
ARE DOING.
>> I'M GLAD HE HATES YOU A
LITTLE BIT MORE THAN ME.
BUT I WAS IN LOUISVILLE, TEXAS
WITH MY DEAR FRIEND, WE WERE
JUST COMING OFF OF MARINA
FOOTBALL.
IN A I HAD ALL OF THESE
IMPORTANT THINGS, WE WENT TO THE
CLUB THAT NIGHT, WE GOT UP IN
THE MORNING AND WE THOUGHT IT
WAS A TV SHOW AND I KEPT
SWITCHING THE CHANNEL'S.
SO THERE'S STILL RESONATING WHAT
IS HAPPENING.
AND SO FOR ME ALTHOUGH I'VE BEEN
GOING TO ACTING THEN, IT WAS
SOMETHING THAT I REALIZED THAT
MY PRIORITIES IN LIFE ARE
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT BECAUSE I'M
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IN THE
WORLD RIGHT NOW AND THAT'S WHY I
STARTED LOOKING INTO POLITICS.
SO FOR ME A REALLY CAUSE ME TO
GROW UP A LITTLE BIT MORE
MENTALLY AND SEE WHAT WE CAN DO.
BECAUSE WE WERE HELPING AND THEY
STARTED STOPPING PEOPLE, SO MANY
PEOPLE VOLUNTEERED TO GO TO NEW
YORK AND THEY DON'T STUFF, GUYS
WERE WORKING, THEY WERE LIKE
HEY, WE CAN HELP, BUT WE FOUND
THINGS THERE.
>> DID YOU WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING?
>> THE ONE THING THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE DIDN'T GET TO EXPERIENCE
THAT WE DID WAS EVERYONE COMING
TOGETHER.
AND THAT FEELING AND THAT
ABILITY.
AND I THINK THAT WE ALL KIND OF
MISSED THAT LONG FOR IT AND WE
KEEP SIPPING SOMETHING IS GOING
TO HAPPEN TO BRING US BACK TO
THAT MOMENT.
>> STILL AHEAD, THE GRAND FINALE
OF MY EPIC INTERVIEW.
COMING UP NEXT, JOE BIDEN SAYS
-- CAN YOU READ THAT?
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT